élections municipales 8e scrutin en un
an en france conséquence une baisse du
taux de participation - 4 4 % par
rapport à 1983
l'estimation à 17h chili le général
pinochet propose une réforme de la
constitution attribue en moins de
pouvoir au président mais certains le
soupçonnent de vouloir lui même se
présenter pour un nouveau mandat
le printemps des instruments anciens
festivals bien particulier à paris les
oeuvres des plus grands compositeurs
comme jean sébastien bach sont joués
avec les instruments et les voix de
l'époque où elles ont été créées à ne
pas manquer reportage dans ce journal
madame monsieur bonsoir alors que
s'achève le 1er tour des élections
municipales les derniers bureaux de vote
fermeront à 20h on peut déjà dire que le
taux de participation est en baisse par
rapport à 1983 et même par rapport à
1977 les deux derniers scrutins en date
à 17 heures la participation en france
était de 59 59 % contre 64 % à la même
heure en 1983 et 63,1 en 1977
à l'occasion de ce huitième scrutin en
france en un an cette augmentation du
taux d'abstention était perçue dans les
sondages de ces dernières semaines est
redouté par les hommes politiques de
droite comme de gauche
nous allons y revenir dans un instant
mais avant cela comment s'est déroulée
cette journée tranquillement sur le
continent un peu moins en corse où une
polémique s'est développé autour de
l'arrivée massive des lecteurs privé du
vote par procuration en raison de la
grève des fonctionnaires
les nationalistes ont aujourd'hui encore
occupé plusieurs tours de contrôle le
plusieurs aéroports pour empêcher les
électeurs d'arrivée nos envoyés spéciaux
françoise joly et dominique merlin se
sont rendus dans un village de haute
corse où cette impossibilité de voter
par procuration pose de sérieux
problèmes vous allez le voir à santa
maria di lota on se sent menacé enfin
monsieur le maire n'est pas tranquille
depuis douze ans il règne sans conteste
sur sa commune ses cinq villages ces
deux mille âmes
mais aujourd'hui il doit faire face à
deux listes concurrentes et surtout
compter avec des procurations qui ne
sont jamais arrivées
plusieurs dizaines de procurations n'ont
pas pu être acheminés jusqu'aux chez
nous alors la question qui se pose est
de savoir si la liste qui l'emportera
aura une majorité qui sera inférieur au
nombre de procurations supérieur à ce
nombre de procurations pourrez tout de
suite les possibilités de recours
contentieux que cela offre à quelqu'un
qui a perdu l'élection à santa maria di
lota on ne polémique pas sur les
charters électoraux sur l'arrivée
massive des lecteurs venus du continent
en revanche on remarque que la
population se mobilise pour ces
élections
on a vu des gens qui venus qui venez
voter physiquement et quelquefois même
très âgées puisque son échec ce dernier
et se faire et dire avec une difficulté
pour vraiment marquer le roi pts est
habituellement ce sont des votes propres
créations
évidemment procuration ou non en corse
ce premier tour des élections
municipales s'est déroulée sans graves
incidents mais l'atmosphère reste tendue
dans l'île
demain l'orage risque d'être social avec
à l'horizon des manifestations et une
troisième semaine de grève pour la
fonction publique
revenons donc maintenant au tour de
participation avec les résultats qui
vous seront donnés à 20 heures précises
les pourcentages au niveau national
maintenant avec pascal remy qui se
trouve au ministère de l'intérieur
pascal oui daniel alors il ya très
exactement 22 millions 285000 et 868
français pas un pli cependant de moins
que se sont rendus aux urnes aujourd'hui
vous le disiez tout à l'heure
le taux de participation à 17h qui le
seul que nous ayons actuellement notre
possession
ce taux de participation s'élève donc à
59,59 % l'abstention dont c'est facile à
calculer 40,4 % à titre de comparaison
avec le précédent scrutin en 83
l'abstention ne s'élevait qu'à 36 % un
taux de participation donc de 64%
donc on a perdu 4,4 pour cent en six ans
pour le même scrutin
on peut décerner les palmes du civisme à
deux départements qui sont l'aude et la
haute saône avec respectivement 77 et
73% beau temps donc plus du trois quart
des inscrits en revanche les lanternes
rouges sont paris on le disait déjà 13
heures et la seine saint denis avec un
peu plus de 40% de votants seulement
donc on avançait des raisons pour ce
tassement à 13 heures elles sont sans
doute encore valable ce soir si la
huitième fois qu'on veut autant un
enfant puisse le premier tour est
traditionnement traditionnellement
pardon moins mobilisateur que le second
donc pour récapituler la tendance
sensible perceptible à midi se trouve
donc confirmer ce soir il y a bel et
bien un tassement les municipales 89 se
présente s'annonce comme un cru plutôt
moyen on devrait avoir entre 72 et 75 %
de votants et cela c'est pas trés trés
bon ni pour la droite ni pour la gauche
merci pascal rapide tour de france
maintenant des vies ou les duels sont
les plus serrées voire les plus
spectaculaires marseille tout d'abord
avec là aussi une participation à la
baisse confirmant l'orientation
nationale que l'on vient de vous donner
roland sicard bernard ap
marseille fêtait aujourd'hui les maires
c'est la semaine du salon nautique et
pourtant tous les maires n'était pas à
la fête
les maires de secteur bien entendu qui
sollicitait un nouveau mandat
une élection sous le signe de la
transparence on utilisait pour la
première fois les urnes en plastique
une élection qui sur le vieux port
laisser les marseillais indice à moins
d'un matériel
je n'aime pas quel gouvernement à
écouter on ne sait pas concerne tenir en
septembre qui voter très important de
oui enfin parce que des marseillais qui
est 17h avait pris le chemin des urnes
pour 48% d'entre eux c'est un peu moins
qu'en 1983
mais lors des dernières municipales les
bureaux de vote fermaient à 18 heures
ils resteront ouverts cette fois deux
heures de plus le temps pour les
retardataires d'aller déposer leur
bulletin
le taux de participation devrait
dépasser en fin de compte les 60% à lyon
et dans le rhône là on parle plus
pointus mais là encore la participation
est en baisse pour l'affrontement entre
le maire francisque collomb et des de
raymond barre et le rpr michel noir
dominique verdeilhan lyon baignant sous
un soleil quasi estival visiter des
échoppes d'artisans sur les quais de la
saône flâner sous les bourgeons naissant
des arbres du parc de la tête d'or était
plus tentant que d'aller faire un tour
dans la fraîcheur sombre des bureaux de
vote
ce climat clément a quand même eu un
mérite électoral celui de convaincre les
leaders politiques d'aller voter
qui francisque collomb le maire cds
sortant ce matin à 11 heures dans le 6e
arrondissement montrant bon pied bon
oeil à 78 mais le sourire un peu crispé
de celui qui ne part pas favori face à
son jeune rival rpr michel noir lui
aussi à pied en famille et à 11 heures
mais dans le troisième arrondissement
secteur clé pour faire basculer la
mairie en sa faveur et élargir sa
structure politique nationale car lyon
devrait rester à droite même si gérard
collomb le candidat socialiste réalise
percée qu'il espère dans le 8è et 9è là
où il veut et ce matin raymond barre lui
qui a fait campagne pour le maire
sortant francisque collomb s'exprimait
dont le troisième où il est menacé d'un
revers qui serait lourd de conséquences
les bureaux ont fermé à 19h enfin du
suspense donc quelques minutes
dernière étape paris la question posée à
paris n'est pas de savoir si monsieur
chirac sera réélu il le sera mais s'il
va perdre quelques arrondissements au
profit de la gauche à paris où l'on a
également moins voté quand 83 laurent
bouvier et oui avec 40,2 points 74 % de
votants à 17h contre 46 95 en 1983 à la
même heure il semble que paris souhaite
une des grandes villes où l'on ait le
moins voté en france cela dit c'est vrai
que les bureaux de vote ne ferme qu'à 20
heures c'est à dire dans un peu moins
d'une heure cela dit vous savez qu'à
paris et comme vous le disiez l'enjeu
n'est pas le maintien à la mairie de
jacques chirac il est pratiquement
assurée de s'y maintenir mais l'enjeu
pour lui c'est de savoir s'il va
réaliser en 1989 le même grand chelem
qu'en 1983 20 arrondissements sur 20
plus dfr père al'inverse pour pierre
joxe et les socialistes parisiens
il s'agit de gagner trois ou quatre
arrondissements pour que le parti
socialistes redeviennent significatif
dans la capitale pour ça les socialistes
comptent sur les arrondissements de
l'est parisien
le 20e le 19e le 13e et le 11e il faut
se rappeler que entre 1977 et 1983
les socialistes la gauche parle on avait
cet arrondissement de paris après le
tour de france des villes tour d'horizon
du vote des personnalités politiques
françaises des images traditionnelles
sourire crépitements de flashs
ils ont montré l'exemple par avion par
hélicoptère ou en voiture aller retour
en avion pour jacques chirac qui a voté
ce matin dès 11 heures dans sa
circonscription de forez plus
particulièrement dans le petit village
de sare ans où il possède le château de
bity sarandon bernadette chirac est
conseillère municipale sortant
c'est en hélicoptère que françois
mitterrand est arrivé à château-chinon
dans la nièvre cet après midi il a
accompli son devoir électoral en
compagnie d'un de ses fils de ses
beaux-frères et belles-soeurs peu avant
17 heures danièle mitterrand épouse du
président en voyage aux etats-unis a
voté l par procuration enfin c'est tout
naturellement voiture que michel rocard
s'est rendu à 17 heures à la mairie de
conflans-sainte-honorine dans les
yvelines pour votre terre en compagnie
de sa femme
michel rocard qui a fait de conflans son
fief municipal retrouve cette année face
à la liste qu'il conduit une liste
communiste
et puis vous le savez sans doute déjà
nouvelle soirée spéciale antenne d
europe 1 paris match à partir de 19h50
la seule chaîne de télévision française
antenne 2 à vous offrir quatre heures de
résultats débats et des surprises
jacques violer notre soirée électorale
signé pierre henri arnstam des corps de
michel millecamps réalisation jean-luc
léridon quatre heures d'information et
de résultats dès 20h avec bbva
estimations sur 17 lieux les équipes
d'antenne 2 sont présentes dans 40
villes de province sur notre plateau
claude sérillon jean louis le scène
gilles leclair albert du roy
alain duhamel patricia charnelet et
rachid arhab vous donnerons tous les
résultats des débats avec des
personnalités politiques et la présence
de jeunes représentants des conseils
municipaux d'enfants
enfin sur minitel 36 15 codes si vite
c'est ivi c vous pouvez en pianotant
connaître les résultats dans les
communes de plus de 3500 habitants dès
19h50 sur notre chaîne votre soirée
élection alors l'actualité n'est pas
simplement municipal aujourd'hui à
l'étranger d'abord la pologne lech
walesa et le gouvernement serait sur le
point de tomber d'accord pour signer un
document rétablissant le syndicat
solidarité dans sa légalité complète
organisant également des élections
libres au mois de juin prochain
constituant une deuxième chambre un
sénat et puis un scrutin
allemand partiellement démocratique
celui là pour élire le parlement 65 %
des sièges restant réservé au parti
officielle au chili le général pinochet
annonce un projet de réforme de la
constitution un référendum pourrait être
organisé au mois de juin prochain et
certains se demandent si en prenant
cette initiative le général n'a pas
l'intention en fait de se présenter aux
élections présidentielles qui auront
lieu à la fin de cette année un moyen
pour lui de surmonter en quelque sorte
l'échec électoral d'il ya cinq mois
les chiliens ayant répondu non au
plébiscite qui devait lui permettre de
conserver le pouvoir jusqu'en 1997
reportage de bernard benyamin et pascal
stelletta c'est ici qu'ont palais de la
moneda que depuis une quinzaine de jours
le général pinochet préparer son projet
de réforme de la constitution
en face de lui alfredo cahe crs le
ministre de l'intérieur l'homme de
confiance général le grand artisan de ce
projet et c'est vrai qu'à le voir la
semaine dernière multiplier les bains de
foule au cours d'un voyage dans le sud
du pays
beaucoup ont commencé à se poser des
questions le général serait il sur le
point d'annoncer sa candidature aux
élections présidentielles de décembre
prochain
ce projet de réforme de la constitution
ne serait-il qu'un artifice cherchant
pas masqué ses véritables intentions
pour le moment lui refuse de répondre à
ces questions il est encore trop tôt dit
il
en fait la seule qui est accepté
d'évoquer le problème c'est sa femme
l'oci est encore le fait qu'elle sous le
contrôle de son mari dans le salon de
leur maison de santiane en tant qu'époux
souhaitez vous que votre mari se
présente aux élections présidentielles
comme épouse
la question est un peu difficile mais
comme femmes chiliennes
j'aimerais que nous ayons le meilleur
pour notre patrie et le meilleur c'est
non je ne sais pas dieu le dira je crois
que nous sommes un peu entre les mains
de dieu entre les mains de dieu et celle
du général pinochet qui régulièrement se
rend à la petite chapelle de la moneda
pour se recueillir
la foi et surtout des sondages
favorables pourrait bien l'amener à
briguer sa propre succession
le 14 décembre prochain à propos du
chili cette semaine dans notre édition
de 20 heures de mardi vous pourrez
suivre un portrait du général pinochet
réalisé par bernard benyamin
et puis mercredi une interview du chef
de l'état chilien le général pinochet
toujours dans notre édition de 20 de la
mafia de nouveau à la une de la presse
italienne le haut commissaire chargé de
lutter contre elles dénoncent les
soi-disant longue maladie des mafiosi
incarcéré certains chefs de clans
siciliens sont à l'hôpital depuis deux
ans maintenant alors que le séjour moyen
dans les hôpitaux italiens est paraît-il
d'après les statistiques de dix jours
pour une maladie ordinaire 68 au plus
pour une maladie de longue durée
et puis la mafia qui n'est jamais à
court d'idées se lance dans une activité
surprenante pour elle puisqu'elle
consiste non pas à racketter mais à
lancer des emprunts versant même des
intérêts comme n'importe quelle autre
banque légale en quête de notre
correspondant en italie marcel trillât
une banque de placement d'un nouveau
genre le jard discret des collecteurs
font d'abord du porte à porte et
recueille les petites et les grosses
économies des braves gens de scordia en
sicile puis chaque mois les collecteurs
repasse pour payer les intérêts des
sommes prêtées
rubis sur l'ongle de l'argent qui
rapporte selon les quantités investi
entre 120 et 240 % par an une affaire en
or
on évalue à plus de la moitié les
habitants du pays qui profiteraient de
l'aubaine parmi eux un seul est passé
publiquement aux aveux la chose n'a été
présentée comme un investissement
financier
j'ai été d'une grande légèreté je
reconnais que j'ai donné de l'argent je
prends mes responsabilités une solution
de la mer responsables de l'état le
collecteur de leonardi était un ancien
agent d'assurances au chômage au cours
d'une descente éclair à son domicile la
semaine dernière la police financière
met la main sur 200 mille francs en
liquide et 5 millions en chèques
il risque tout au plus une inculpation
pour fraude fiscale aucune loi italienne
interdit clairement la collecte privé
d'argent frais par los angels joe un
homme qui n'aime guère la publicité vous
devez m'excuser ça suffit mon père n'est
là pour personne
il est ici mais il ne veut pas parler
non pourquoi
qu'est ce que j'en sais moi
un jeune professeur conseiller municipal
d'extrême gauche aspord ya même campagne
et tente sans succès de provoquer la
création d'une commission denquête
municipal pour lui pas de doute
une affaire qui rapporte six gros il y a
un truc à ma via un grand besoin de
capitaux propres pour investir dans le
trafic de drogue et pour recycler
l'argent sale elle a un grand besoin de
financer les entreprises qui ensuite on
est la main sur les grandes publications
de l'argent il y en a dans ce gros bourg
de la plaine de catane spécialisée dans
la culture et le commerce des oranges
des dizaines de millions de francs
auraient déjà été collectés par les
financiers de l'ombre or d'après les
experts un franc bien investi dans le
trafic de drogue peut rapporter environ
150 mille francs par an les cageots
d'orange des uns peuvent se muer
miraculeusement pour les autres en
lingots d'or et la mafia ne présente
guère quand il s'agit de gros sous onze
assassinats scordia ces dernières années
et peu de goût pour les petits curieux
que nous insistions un peu trop pour
rencontrer des personnages d'impliquer
dans cette affaire un homme en voiture
est venu nous proposer très
courtoisement un petit tour du pays pour
parler sans message était très clair
ce que vous cherchez ne veulent pas vous
et puis la télévision ferait sans doute
mur de montrer les belles choses
jusqu'où peut s'intéresser à sur
l'histoire
message bien reçu élections municipales
encore mais cette fois ci en allemagne
fédérale élections municipales dans le
land de hesse avec une forte chute de
les chrétiens-démocrates et pousser ce
qui est plus inquiétant poussée de
l'extrême-droite 3% des voix c'est la
deuxième poussée de l'extrême droite en
allemagne fédérale depuis celle du mois
de janvier c'est à berlin ouest en
france fait divers tragique à lens un
petit garçon de 11 ans tué d'une balle
en pleine tête hier soir alors qu'il se
trouvait à côté d'un manège d'une fête
foraine et policiers ont aussitôt repéré
la trajectoire de la balle et interpellé
le propriétaire de larmes qui a tué et
qui se trouvait dans un appartement à
proximité l'homme est actuellement
interrogé par la police
épilogue d'un confit social qui aura
duré un mois tout juste à saint brieuc
en bretagne dans l'entreprise de
chaudières et de chauffe eau chaffoteaux
et maury reprise il y a trois ans par un
groupe north africain avec engagement de
ne pas licencier
l'entreprise est aujourd'hui dit-elle
contrainte de le faire ce que la cgt
n'accepte pas mais le personnel en
définitive a décidé de reprendre tout de
même le travail dès demain en quête de
delphine de la selle et philippe duval
troubadour des temps modernes vincent
chante la grève
l'angoissé et la colère des travailleurs
depuis près d'un mois la région
briochine et privé de ses chaudières
l'usiné fermée décision du patron après
séquestration d'écart l'origine du
conflit
une liste nominative de 56 licenciements
première phase sur trois ans la
direction a prévu 600 suppressions
d'emplois nous devrons dû nous rendre
compte à l'évidence que une politique du
plein emploi par la fuite en avant ne
réussissait pas bénéfice net
nous avons à fin juin 88 constat constat
d'échec puisque nous étions à 121
millions de pertes
pour marie thérèse strullu cette réalité
économique est inacceptable employé de
bureau elle travaille depuis dix ans
dans cette entreprise
apprécié par ses collègues elle ne
comprend pas pourquoi elle figure sur la
liste une entrevue avec mon chef de
service qui m'a bien affirmé que le
poste n'était pas supprimée et que
quelqu'un d'autre obligatoirement
prendre à ma place le spectre des
licenciements plane depuis 84
chaffoteaux et maury est alors au bord
du gouffre à deux doigts du dépôt de
bilan
son repreneur un financier algérien qui
croient à l'avenir du gaz
ce dernier s'engage à investir 100
suppressions d'emplois condition
sinequanone subventions d'état en 89
le pari se révèle impossible la dette et
regroupe les prix de revient peu
concurrentiel aujourd'hui nous préparons
l'europe 92 on a besoin d'un partenaire
européen
tout candidat qui dit à nos côtés ne
peut pas
rentré dans cette affaire si
l'association n'est pas signé d'abord
par nous et de voir si le site saint
brieuc est un site sur lequel nous
pouvons miser
nous avons fait tout ce qu'il fallait
faire nous avons sorti un plan qui nous
a coûté très cher 60 millions de francs
et a pas une entreprise en france qui a
proposé un plan social aussi humains ne
sont pas venus ici pour faire la
stabilité sociale
la cgt syndicat majoritaire refuse en
bloc les offres de la direction
elles demandent purement et simplement
le maintien de tous les emplois c'est
travail reprend lundi et nous voulons
malgré tout préserver la force des
travailleurs et leur cohésion et nous
choisirons peut-être d'autres formes de
l'utr pour aboutir à éviter les 56
licenciements et les suppressions
d'emplois malgré l'appel au boycott
lancé par la cgt
64 % des salariés ont voté pour la
reprise du travail
il ne souhaite qu'une chose continuer à
croire aux chances de survie de leur
entreprise
spectacle pour nous détendre un peu
maintenant à paris actuellement le
printemps des instruments anciens en
france l'idée est de jouer les oeuvres
des plus grands compositeurs comme ce
jean sébastien bach dans les conditions
où elles ont été donnés à l'époque de
leur création une théorie défendue
principalement pas le chef d'orchestre
gustav leonhardt cette volonté de retour
aux sources est aussi vous allez le voir
une mine de surprises reportage de
michel perron et bernhard wehrli
ans
o o
oh
ainsi le voulait la règle à l'époque de
bach des femmes est interdite de chants
à l'église
ce sont donc deux jeunes garçons qui
chantaient les parties écrites pour les
registres élevé gustav leonhardt depuis
plus de 30 ans milite pour des
interprétations conforme aux sonorités
qu'abc entendait dans composants légers
jamais mis en question d autres
interprétations mais plutôt j'ai
toujours essayé de regarder la partition
et tous les recycle ce constance positif
de l'époque barré mais le public est
libre de choisir ce qu'il lui plaît et
pour moi je change jamais mon opinion
d'une oeuvre à cause d'un public
intransigeance rigueur mais sans
dogmatisme la froideur que l'on
reprochait à leonard qu'à ses débuts
semble s'être estompée avec le temps
toujours quand on est jeune on est plus
intéressé dans le détail des choses
qu'on a découvert mort montré en plus
actifs et en perd souvent la grande vu
la cohérence sur tout et je voyage
souvent n'importe justement ça
et
oh
le sport maintenant la première grande
classique cycliste l'année paris nice
remporté par le nouvel espoir espagnol
miguel indurain qui a battu stephen
roche le favori jean paul ollivier
stephen roche d'ailleurs peut-il vaincre
il reste deux de nuit et à nice et le
col des roches se demandent comment
faire les rénove son puissant et
continue à protéger remarquablement leur
maillot blanc indurain et pourtant
stéphane roche tente le tout pour le
tout dans la descente du col de vence
il attaque qui se lancent à sa poursuite
indurain le maillot blanc en personne
belles passes d'armes à nice victoire de
l'italien baffie mais 43 secondes
toujours c'est par indurain et roche le
verdict au sommet du col d'eze
cet après midi roche est décidé à se
battre jusqu'au bout
il reprend 22 secondes à mi course
ein du rail indurain c'est derrière
qu'il a fort à faire au spécialiste
cayroche
une fois de plus le compte à rebours est
déclenché roche gagne l'étape
il va reprendre 32 secondes à indurain
les pour trait ce monde il perd paris
nice
il durera une vainqueur mais le retour
de roche au premier plan est aussi le
grand enseignement de la course autre
vainqueur cet après-midi dans le tiercé
qui se courait à auteuil vous allez voir
les gagnants s'inscrire sur votre écran
le 6 le 10 et le 11 rapports 3228 francs
50 et pour ce qui concerne le quarté +
vous ajoutez le 16 et vous gagnez 7867
franc
voilà ce journal est terminée tout de
suite après bien sûr les prévisions
météo avec josé blanc lapierre et puis
19h50 donc notre soirée spéciale
élections municipales tout ce que vous
devez savoir et comprendre sur ce
premier tour
à partir de 19h50 vous souhaite une
excellente soirée sur notre chaîne et je
vous dis à samedi prochain bonsoir